how's your dad by the way he's so good
hey yeah he's doing good buddy he
screwed up his uh like all the stuff
that they replace I guess for the the a
TV action yes yeah so he like tripped
over a shoe getting into bed after
peeing and he just like you know some of
these a lot at night yeah
few I think constant I was up literally
six times last night really yeah it's a
lot Wow here's what I'm worried about
though the fact that you just said that
Jim will now when he gets up six times
to pee he won't go to the doctor because
he'll go it's okay still touring when
he's healthy right yeah you really do
live by what would Ozzie do he's done so
much and he's still healthy at his age
that like nothing I'm doing is gonna
equal that you're right you're right so
he's okay he's you know tour again in
2020 yeah yeah is he depressed oh yeah
so bummed out really oh yeah you should
come over and make him off I suggested
that you might listen to no we're going
away
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM Adam